Hello?
Freak bitches.
Yeah.
Well we just spent the same,
say I did some magnetic chick to my brain.
Wow.
Yeah.
I go,
I feel like I'm your,
your,
your depression correspondent.
Like I go out and do crazy shit.
I did that.
I'll,
all right,
so it's called tr.
I talked about it last time was here.
I was going to do it.
I did,
um,
I did ketamine,
which I got to say I cannot recommend.
Really?
Yeah,
I did three.
No,
actually I did six sessions.
Uh,
which was crazy.
Did it.
But the side effects long term were my eyes burnt for straight up two to three
months every day.
Um,
yeah.
Houses like burn,
like I needed drops constantly.
Like I'm like you stare at the Sun burnt when the like,
like irritated.
I'm like,
you got something in them.
Yeah.
More like that.
Uh,
and I just felt like kind of groggy and out of it for a couple months.
Really?
Yeah.
Then I did explain,
so ketamine glossier.
Yeah.
Well,
I talked about it last time I was here,
but yeah,
cause I got a lot of talk about you were going to do it or you don't.
It may be I was going to do it.
I think you had done it.
Yeah,
I had done it and I was,
it was still too early to tell,
but I remember running into in the hall the comedy store and you were super
happy.
It was amazing.
The first time I did it,
the first two sessions were great and then after that I kind of hit a plateau
and,
and the,
I just kind of felt like,
just kinda like groggy for a not kidding,
like a couple months.
So the first session you,
did you get this positive benefit from it?
Yeah,
they point in continuing,
uh,
because the,
the,
the treatment is six sessions.
The protocol,
that's the protocol.
So,
um,
hold on.
I think I have video of it too.
Whoa.
I know I have video witching and you're just in a,
basically in like a hospital room and uh,
and experience itself you said was full blown psychedelic,
straight up fucking 100% tripping,
tripping balls.
And this is all FDA approved.
Uh,
it's FDA approved as an anesthetic.
Right.
It's not FDA approved.
I actually know it.
It's getting the,
I think it is.
They're actually because otherwise wouldn't be able to talk about it.
Yeah.
Uh,
it is approved as an off label,
uh,
depression treatment off labels.
Tricky Shit,
isn't it?
Yes.
Because there's no,
they don't know.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I mean that's all of them in some ways,
especially with antidepressants.
It's all like,
yeah,
this might,
this might could do something,
maybe not.
I liked that.
There's stuff that they can do to you that is definitely beneficial,
but it's just,
you know,
your insurance isn't gonna cover it.
If you have the cash,
you can pay for it.
Yeah.
That's,
that's kind of the situation I was in where it's like nobody was going to pay
for it.
But if you want to roll the dice and I rolled the dice and I got to say,
but you,
do you think that if the initial treatments that you had,
the first couple that you really had good responses from,
if you just stop there,
you'd have a different opinion of it.
I don't know.
That's the thing is if I had just done at once,
it kind of felt like you ever do acid.
Yes.
You know that like paying that like super clear feeling.
That's how I felt the day I saw you.
I did ask him for the first time,
like I was,
I want to say four months ago.
Oh Wow.
Months ago.
That's great.
What'd you think?
Loved it.
Yeah.
You didn't find it too intense?
No.
Okay.
Because it can be speedy as fuck.
I'm so used to edibles and float tanks.
Yeah.
That I think it's,
uh,
it's very interesting.
It was very clean,
like the eye,
the idea behind it,
like the,
uh,
the,
the feeling behind it,
the thought process behind it.
I was like,
Ooh,
this is like some mine clarifier.
It's like,
like,
you know,
Bill Hicks,
he used to call it a squeegee and your third,
I like mushrooms.
That's,
it felt,
it felt very,
uh,
clarifying if that makes any sense.
But of course it makes total sense.
I felt great.
I felt really good.
Felt really friendly
during.
Yeah,
man,
like real musta had good stuff.
Cause a lot of times it can be speedy and it ends up feeling like mushrooms and
I think mushroom math.
Oh,
combined you're saying?
Yeah.
You end up with this just like intense fucking,
it's not the God damn problem is that it's illegal.
Okay.
You're getting weird versions of it.
Here's your thing,
here's the doctor putting the Ivm IIR okay.
Oh Jesus.
Can I say it?
Yeah.
Oh Christ.
Okay.
Did you take this with the 1980s phone?
No,
that's just the way it's saved or whatever.
Why does it seem so little?
I don't know.
This is blue.
Are you blowing okay?
No,
I can't.
All right.
So this doctor is,
uh,
he looked like Bob Shapiro.
Ojs Council.
Oh,
just lead counsel.
You can
corner.
Um,
so we just,
you just go into a regular doctor's office and sticks this thing in your own
thing in your arm and off you go.
Now the doctor has,
he tried it himself.
Uh,
he would not say,
but it was,
he said it with a wink that he had.
He was like,
I won't comment either way on whether I've done it myself.
So all those guys,
they wanted to keep it on the sneak tip.
Yeah.
But clearly he had and so yeah.
So I would say for for the first session was amazing.
That's when I saw you.
And then after that it got a little dicey.
Now what does it feel like when you're in it?
I was in a,
it felt like I was in a pod,
a pod in like a small,
it's a small world after all like Pod,
I'm going into the [inaudible] now crossing my arms and I would like a little
boat just going along through rooms and the rooms I would say were designed like
kind of a bit like a,
what's the a clockwork orange but like the,
the milk bar thing,
a bit like white walls,
white breathing walls and yeah,
breathing.
I'd say they were breathing.
Yeah they were inhaling and exhaling and,
but I was never freaked out and then there was like kind of digits on it.
Like the Matrix,
it had like a green hue to it.
Um,
my biggest worry when I was in it was like I'm so out of it.
If there's an earthquake I'm fucked like I am.
And then I would get like wide shots of California.
We'll get like wide shots of California and take about like the hospital
crumbling.
And then I've me trying to get out and go and like I can't go man,
you're not going to have to go without me.
Give me 40 minutes and I'll catch up to you guys.
Uh,
so that was my biggest worry,
but for the most part it was just like a fairly pleasant,
I just couldn't get over the fact that this was happening in a doctor's office.
Right.
It's just like a regular ass fucking doctor.
Like literally waiting room with other physicians and their patients.
Old Weirdos,
Ma,
it's shitty magazines.
And then you go in and you trip your fucking head off and so you're sitting in
like a regular chair.
You're sitting,
it's a,
it's a recliner,
double bed cosmetic type thing.
Oh yeah.
It's real nice.
They spared,
no,
he's nuts.
So you're sitting in this craftmatic adjustable bed,
um,
you,
you get the needle in the arm and they leave it in there for how long?
40 40 minutes.
40 minutes.
Now if an earthquake happened,
could you just pull the needle out of your arm?
And it was so out of it.
I don't think I could have.
I think once the drip happened,
like it's in you for a while.
Uh,
so what's the drip happens?
You probably have however long.
I mean it's a 40 minute trip apparently,
but I don't know if it's based on one,
if it's,
I don't know how much is going in at once.
Now that stuff,
ketamine is weird because it's,
um,
it was a tranquilizer,
right.
For animals.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's a,
it's a,
it's a horse tranquilizer and they use it as an anesthesia for humans.
Yeah,
I've heard of that.
The guy was an anesthesiologist.
He was,
yeah.
Don't they use that in war time?
Because it's easy to carry around.
I believe they have in war time because you can use very small amounts and it
puts people under,
you know what that sounds like.
That sounds like a Joe Rogan fact.
Yeah.
I don't know for sure.
But it sounds like,
yes.
I think,
uh,
I'm pretty sure that's the case.
I'm pretty sure.
Uh,
I was listening to a podcast with her talking about various forms of anesthesia
and sort of the evolution of using anesthesia and that ketamine worked really
good in the field because you could have a very small amount and you would,
you know,
put someone under pretty deeply.
I don't know.
What if it's local?
Do you know what I mean?
Like,
I don't know if you could have done surgery.
It wasn't like I couldn't feel myself.
Right.
It was more like I had no interest in it.
When you got here following FDA approval in 1971 did that Asia was first given
to American soldiers during the Vietnam War.
Oh,
there you go.
Uh,
yeah.
There's a lot of shit on reddit about,
about it as an,
as an antidepressant treatment.
Frantic for depression.
So for you,
um,
you heard about this,
how,
I don't know.
I want to say if you just Google depression treatments,
so you just worked growing my age too,
or alternative depression treatment is probably what I,
what I Google now we've had these conversations before you and I have found
about depression and different treatments.
How much exercise do you do?
A,
did we talk about this before?
I send them out?
I've run probably three,
four days a week.
That's pretty nice.
Yeah.
That's supposed to be one of the best things.
Depressions.
Yeah.
Cardio.
But like I've never gotten a runner's high,
if that makes sense.
Really.
I think I have a shortage of dopamine in my brain.
Just naturally.
Like I just think I don't have a ton of dough mean like I don't,
joy is not a thing I think I've ever experienced.
What I repeat joy is a thing that I don't think I've ever experienced.
I'll experience adrenaline rushes and like ego but I'll never be truly like
Julius.
Yeah,
it stinks.
It fucking stinks cause it's something I'm,
I I believe in,
I just don't,
I've accomplished things I've done,
you know what I mean?
But I never get this sense of like this real,
you know,
in very small doses.
Vic extremely like micro doses.
So like let me put into perspective like career wise,
like yeah,
you had a nice comedy central special,
they put a lot of hype behind it.
You did.
I watched,
he did really well.
Got a great response.
How'd you feel when all that was over?
I felt cool.
Cool.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I felt like,
yeah,
exactly.
Like all right,
good shit man.
Keep going.
See what else.
Yeah.
But it was never like during Chappelle show,
I never got like,
I am the king of the world.
You know what I mean?
Like never that sort of like huge,
uh,
you know,
something that would make you want to scream.
You feel so good.
Right.
Do you get that much all day?
24,
seven.
I just hold it in and trying not to scream.
If you want to take a break,
if you want to go up on the roof.
I'm the worst guy to talk to this about because I don't really,
I don't really get depressed.
I've been depressed before,
but answering my question,
the joint question,
I'm joyful all the time.
So that wasn't a joke.
You've really,
I'm pretty happy.
That's great.
Here's the good news.
You seem happy.
Yeah.
Like I don't,
I buy it.
I'm not laying his fucking Joe.
Joe Rogan thinks he's happy.
You seem happy.
I have a lot of friends.
Yeah.
Like that's a big part of it.
You know,
a lot of cool friends.
I love,
uh,
I love having a family.
Love what I do.
Yeah.
Like my jobs,
my day is filled with stuff I enjoy doing.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's just fucking,
I'm just lucky.
Yeah.
Super loud.
But I have many of the same things.
Yeah.
I just don't feel that that sense of satisfaction you,
you have now,
it varied.
Have you had higher and lower feelings of satisfaction?
Yeah,
I think when I'm working a lot I feel pretty satisfied.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
So accomplishments or task,
task and goal oriented.
Like I like,
it's satisfying to deal with special or direct a commercial or,
or,
or write a TV show or,
you know,
well,
I'll tell you one thing.
I say I'm filled with joy and I'm happy all the time when I'm not working or I'm
not accomplishing anything or I'm not doing,
like if I get like real lazy,
I can get depressed.
Somebody else told me that they said that a very,
very joyous guy told me when he gets injured,
he just,
that takes it out of him.
Ken,
I've been injured gang of times.
I've had a bunch of surgeries from,
um,
you know,
athletic injuries.
But,
um,
for me,
uh,
if I go into Lowe's,
like if I'm not accomplishing things or in the past I don't allow myself to get
into those anymore because it's just not a good feeling.
And even,
it doesn't even necessarily have to be like a career like oriented thing,
but I have to have things that I'm enjoying.
Yeah.
It could just be like,
I'm really in doing yoga,
I'm doing yoga every day I do it,
I get it done and now I feel great and yeah.
But if I'm not doing something I,
my brain for whatever reason,
needs tasks,
it needs stuff to do and need stuff to figure out.
It needs like puzzles.
Yeah.
If I don't get that I have,
I have real issue.
Yeah.
Agreed.
Do you like big longterm goals?
It's like,
yeah,
you do.
Yeah.
I'd like to handles it or micro thing.
I like,
I like those too.
I like things that are due in like a week as opposed to something that's like,
yeah,
whenever you're like,
I'm outlining a movie right now,
and I'm like,
yeah,
but I don't,
I wish it were more like bang,
Bang.
Yeah.
Like I'm meeting about it tomorrow.
Like specifically to,
so to like kind of focus myself.
Like you write a joke and then you go up do it tonight and he kills like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's okay.
That's something that,
that's joy.
That's pretty generic.
Their joy.
Yeah.
Knowing or just writing a joke,
a joke that it can and it kills.
It's like dad feeling,
man.
Don't you wish you could give that to people who don't do stand up?
Yep.
I sure do.
I mean,
it's just like,
it's,
it.
I've,
I've had this conversation with people before that don't do stand up and I'm
like,
man,
I wish I could tell you what it's like to crush in front of 5,000 people finding
$100,000.
Do you know what I mean?
That's how it feels.
It feels like,
oh,
I just found $100,000.
And you know what led me there?
My personality and my experience coming in,
incoming me nervous.
Um,
yeah.
So this,
this tms thing,
transcranial magnetic stimulation covered by Blue Cross,
huh?
Yeah.
Uh,
so yeah,
that's what like it's,
it's,
it was really,
really good.
Like I,
for a lot of my life I felt like I had a all right,
I had like a,
a,
a thing like a,
it almost felt like a metal weight,
like a bit of like five pound weight on my upper left forehead,
my left.
And then so I went to this Whoa,
dude,
that sound is like an Mri.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
It is.
Yes.
It's basically the same exact magnet as an MRI.
What?
It's just made your day.
Yeah.
They put it on your head.
It's pretty simple.
The first time they measure it,
they have to get to like the exact spot.
There's,
and there's another video where my finger is pulsing that you'll enjoy.
And what is it doing to you?
Like what's the benefit?
Uh,
it's basically magnetizing and electrifying a,
it's waking up,
basically did a synopsis according to them.
Really?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's waking up dead synapses and,
uh,
picking up dead,
waking them up so they're dormant.
Ah,
that's what they say.
Um,
you don't even look into it.
You're like,
good,
shoot me out here.
What is it?
Can I do quarter one?
And this one time I don't have kids,
man.
So I'm like,
yeah,
I don't give a shit,
whatever,
whatever it's going to cost me.
I'm happy to do it.
If you had kids,
you think you wouldn't do it?
I think kids,
I'd be like,
you know,
sort of more,
more cautious about it were young.
Yeah,
probably.
Cause I'm,
I'm not like reckless,
but I'm not,
I'm not like,
uh,
I do research.
It's also vague anyway.
Mm.
The research,
it's also like,
we think it does this.
Most antidepressants,
they know,
they think they know what's happening.
They don't actually know.
Yeah.
That's a weird one.
When you think about how many people are prescribed these things and then
there's not really a direct understanding of how it impacts each p East person.
They'll tell you,
hey,
we'll try this medication and if it doesn't work,
we'll try another one.
Yeah.
Does this one work?
We'll just cycle through it.
And how do you know if it's working for you or if you're having a good time in
your life and so you're feeling better because maybe you started a new
relationship and a new job and it's going wow.
And Hey,
it just a,
everything seems pretty good.
I was on medications that made me nauseous for a year and a half before I was
like,
you know what?
I literally thought I was nauseous because I was eating too many lifesavers.
Not even fucking kidding.
Literally I was like,
I gotta take it easy on these life savers because every night I throw up on the
way to the laugh factory and then I realized like,
you know,
Neil,
you're taking a pretty high dosage of Zoloft,
or you might want to just take it down a notch.
That Zoloft stuff is supposed to be really weird for your discerning of what
matters and what doesn't matter.
Like,
like it's hard to,
I've never done it so it's,
it's hard for me to describe it.
But yeah,
the people that I've talked to that had done it and said,
one of the issues that they had with it is nothing had the bad things,
didn't feel bad anymore,
but the good things didn't feel good either.
Well that's thing with a lot of antidepressants is they,
they raise the,
the floor and they also the ceiling,
we'll so that it,
it narrows your band of experience basically.
Whew.
Uh,
which,
but if you're severely depressed,
it can be very like,
like ketamine apparently is a lifesaver truly for,
they may start administering it in,
uh,
in emergency rooms for suicide cases.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause it does,
it's dry.
I mean it's a basic,
a whole,
it's a hallucinogen.
So you know,
hallucinogens well makes you like,
it,
see,
thinks differently.
So there's starting to,
uh,
I at least they're talking about administering it as a,
as a,
uh,
sort of,
almost like,
uh,
whatever that drug is that you can do.
Almost like an Epi pen for,
for,
uh,
for suicide victims towards suicide thought thinkers,
thinkers,
or,
yeah,
I'm about to do it.
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
so the,
so the tms,
transcranial magnetic stimulation,
half an hour of that,
of that debt,
that debt,
the debt doesn't feel like much,
feels like a,
like a Shitty Woodpecker,
like a fucking sleepy woodpecker is sort of going at your head,
but you're not like,
Hey,
get out of here.
Well,
you're just kind of like,
okay,
okay.
Huh.
How much longer?
And you,
I would just sit there and watch TV.
Um,
and how many times he's supposed to do it.
I do it 40 times.
Four zero four zero times.
Half an hour.
And how deep are you in right now?
I'm done.
I finished it.
Yeah,
I did all 40 in the fall.
Wow.
And,
uh,
and I'm telling you it lasted and um,
and you can go back for,
for,
um,
like sort of pick me ups every,
whenever you feel like you need it.
Um,
so I'm telling you like this is the thing that has worked best for me better
than ketamine if way,
but better than,
than Zoloft.
Better than healing.
I was on,
uh,
what's an Ssri?
Is this a strategic Sarah to selective Serotonin reuptake inhibitor?
Um,
and uh,
and went off at once.
I did this magnet shit.
So you know,
you're off everything.
Yeah.
Wow.
And you feel great.
Yeah.
Just no joy.
Well,
no joy,
but that's not what,
he never had it.
You didn't lose nothing.
I just look at you.
Yeah,
you kids have fun.
I'll be over here.
Yeah.
But it's not,
I'm not miserable and I'm not also,
there's no physical manifestation.
That's the biggest thing.
The,
the,
the head thing,
the feeling like there was a plate on my head.
Getting rid of that was really,
really,
really great.
So when you say like a plate on your head,
like there was a pressure or,
yeah,
I have a little weight,
a little weight and a little pressure.
Did you ever nervous when I went in there?
No,
because there were times where I'd go off of uh,
antidepressants and I have my jaw muscles and muscles in my temple would be so
tight that I'd need to use like a massager well on them.
So I knew that there was all,
it was all sort of connected.
Um,
you got,
you do ding on.
Is that,
was that pretty sure that my thing,
unless it's me,
it might've,
is there name bro?
[inaudible]
Bro.
Yeah.
Was,
yeah.
Was Your Day fuck up there?
Okay.
Um,
so,
so that was a big one.
That was really helpful.
Then I did a,
I was in New York for a couple of months.
Did that show three mikes?
Um,
which I think I told you the premise,
the,
yeah,
you told me,
but tell him,
say it.
So the premise is onstage,
I put three Mikes equidistant apart from each other.
One is for stand up,
one is for one liners that I just couldn't fit anywhere.
And then one is for true sort of emotional confessions type shit.
Talking about depression,
talking about a shit with my dad.
Um,
like the sort of the,
I won't spoil the surprise but pretty heavy shit between my me and my dad when
he died or right before he died.
And,
and then the,
and then the second monologue is about,
um,
kind of about like celebrity and,
and,
and dealing with,
with having a partner and then break it up and become my own guy and all that
shit.
So it's basically like,
it ends up being probably 40 minutes to stand up,
45 stand up in a half hour of true stories and then five minutes of one liners.
And did you do it after you had completed your treatment?
I did,
yes.
I did it after,
yeah.
And in the middle of it I actually stopped taking everything and in the middle
of recording or practice in the middle of,
no,
in the middle of the run,
I had an eight week run,
I think in New York.
And,
uh,
and I stopped everything in the middle of it.
It's not like suddenly just like,
I don't think I need it.
Wow.
Yeah.
Now,
what were the,
what's the difference when you get off medication?
What was the,
the difference in the way your brain was functioning?
I can almost tell how well my brain's functioning if I'm not depressed or not
slowed down by depression.
My associations are much quicker.
Like if you're just like the simplest thing of like,
that guy looks like so and so like,
uh,
sort of a little roast,
like a little like what is that shirt fucking looks like the kind of shirt you
like.
If I'm not depressed,
I can think of those quickly.
Uh,
if I'm depressed,
there were times where I'd get depression would affect my memory,
where I couldn't remember the,
the,
the test I would always do in my head is there's a guy who directed,
gone with a win and the wizard of Oz back to back.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Uh,
and I would try to remember his name.
His name's Victor Fleming,
but if I was depressed,
I couldn't remember it.
Like it affects your fucking,
do you think
resource thing,
like your brain is so concentrating on the depression and feeling like shit that
just doesn't have the resources
think it,
I tend to think it's more a dead sinaps thing.
Hmm.
And I think it's a,
I think it's an energy.
I think depression is a lack of energy in the brain.
So,
and maybe you're right.
Maybe it is.
It's all going to one place,
but that's my own personal interpretation of it.
Okay.